all right everyone i guess we can start
a second
let's have anything okay
so um welcome back
caffeinated um
so uh just a quick reminder we talked
about competitive analysis we gave the
definition
uh we saw two these two examples rank or
buy
uh ski rental in this cat and mouse
uniform search no search on a uniform
metric
and
we saw
algorithms which were pretty much
optimal so for this one we saw
deterministic algorithms that were 2
minus 1 over b randomized algorithms
that were e over e minus 1 and the limit
as b tends to infinity for cat and mouse
we saw deterministic algorithms that
were n comparative we didn't see lower
bounds
but maybe you know i can talk about it
some other time and we saw
randomized algorithms that were log n
comparative
and you might be wondering uh you know
cat and mouse is the very cute game but
where does this fit in right what's the
big picture
what are we
supposed to take away from that well you
know firstly
the idea of doing this search
you're searching for this magical
location
where the cat might not be visiting or
whether it's visiting last
and you're marking so that you make only
log n hops before you reach that magical
location is a very powerful idea and
it's an idea that you should keep in
mind uh
you know as a search primitive
so let me you know at least mention
where all this leads so here's one way
of writing the cat and mouse game uh so
here's what's going to happen at time t
i'll see a cost vector
c t
and this belongs to
let's say the positive rails
of n dimensions
and what i have to do is i have to play
a vector
x t
which belongs to the probability simplex
so this is just saying that you know x
is defining a probability distribution
over their locations
and let's say that maybe i'm also going
to say that x t is going to be in 0 1 to
the
it's i mean it's just a one in one
location and zero everywhere it's where
my
where the mouse is sitting
think of the following thing that the
cat ct at i
is going to be
infinity if the cat is there
and 0 if the cat is not there
what do i want to do
i want to minimize
summation
dxt
plus
sum over time of xt
what i want this is just the cat and
mouse game
i can't be at the location where the cat
is infinite cost
and i want to minimize
this looks kind of similar right i mean
this is kind of what uh shipra high
paying we're talking about you know in
the regret kind of bounce we are
interested in this
actually almost this
let me just
relate this
to in regret what we do is we do the
following c t
x t minus one
the algorithm pays place first
and then the adverse replays next
is this i'm getting a look ahead i'm
seeing the cost vector before i make my
action
slight difference
there's no there's no term there's no
movement term out here
in the regret
but we are comparing ourselves to the
best best
uh fixed strategy best fixed action in
hindsight
so this was regret
this is what we are solving
um
and this is the problem that you know i
talked about
uh this problem in general
is called the
okay i'll just write down the term uh
where should i write it down
metrical
task systems horrible name but uh you
know it's a it's a
on the uniform metric
just you know the uniform metric is
captured by the fact that
moving movement distances are unit
between uh distinct locations
the metrical task systems problem is is
is a very general problem
and you can
generalize this to instead of saying
it's the l1 distance you can think of
this as the earth mover distance or the
wasserstein distance
according to some general metric between
x t and x t minus one
and then this becomes the general
metrical task systems problem
very powerful abstraction
and the ideas that we give
suitably generalized will give
algorithms for metrical task systems as
well
you might ask you know why do i care
about metrical gas systems
metrical task systems
a lot of problems you can formulate as
metrical task systems
so for instance you can imagine the
following thing
you can think of
caching
you have n pages in main memory slow
memory
you have k pages you have a fast cache
of size k and n is much bigger
requests come in and when a request
comes in so a request is for a page
if this page is in the cache you don't
pay anything
but if this page is not in the cache
and the cache is full you might have to
evict some page from the cache and then
bring this page in
you want to minimize the number of
evictions
this is the caching problem
now what you can do
is you can imagine
that every
so okay
um why is this a metrical task system
this is like got nothing to do with
metric spaces and things like this right
so here is one way in which this is a
metrical system
there are
states
every state of my algorithm is the
contents of my cache
how many states are there
and choose k
so so this is you know state 1 this is
state 2 there are n choose k many
possible states
and now my algorithm just says you know
i'm sitting at one of these states
um
in response to my request you know
so now what's going to happen is if this
state if i get a request for page five
and page five is not in my cache
this will give me an infinite cost out
here
we'll give an infinite cost on all
states which don't have page five in
their cache
so i have to move to a
state which has page five in its cache
and the cost for that is really the
difference
between
number of pages maybe c1 minus c2 or
something
the number of pages i would have to
change to go from c one to c
so i can define a metric
it's this large state space
but it's a metrical task system
and so if you have an algorithm for
metrical task systems boom immediately
you have an algorithm for
caching
you have an algorithm for a very vast
vast
where my reason w is always me up
growing up in india
so uh yeah
how you formulated the problem
so this is the measure of my cost and
i'll always compare to the optimal cost
right
so
imagine like i fixed the horizon
would probably be different if i'm not
trying to maximize competitive ratio or
just minimize cost
so i'm always trying to in this case
minimize the competitive ratio so i'm
always trying to say arguments of this
form
that
my algorithm should have cos c t x t
plus x t minus x t minus 1
is at most
let's say
alpha times
c t y t
plus y t minus y t minus 1.
all possible solutions why
and i'm trying to minimize this alpha
right
so the adversary can pick
those instances that are also where up
is very low to push that ratio on
absolutely so when opt is low i should
be low and when opt is higher
absolutely
oh by the way suppose caching there are
suppose let's just look at this special
case n equals k plus one
so how many states are there
there are n states
each contains
k minus one n minus one of the
things right n minus one of the pages
it does not contain one of the pages
think of the mouse is sitting on that
page
end pages the mouse is sitting on one
page
the request for that page comes the cat
moves there
the mouse has to move somewhere else
that's like evicting that page
so this this situation is exactly the
category
if you want to get an algorithm for
caching you have to generalize the cat
mask
and that's that marking algorithm that i
showed you can be generalized to caching
in general
yes
i can see it
it's an excellent question
so
right the competitive analysis was
initially designed to be you know it's
its robustness is the first priority
so it's it's very adversarial
in its thinking
but
over the past you know 10 15 20 years
people have been trying to relax this
adversarial nature you know can we get
algorithms which are good
on the average in some sense shuchi will
talk about that
and then we'll also talk about aspects
of that
so and and then there's this more
interesting phenomenon recently where
you can try to say look i want to be no
worse than this worst case but on good
instances i should be even better
that's a very very commendable direction
i i really like it
good
so the cat and mouse game is a special
case of caching
because of this example that i just gave
you for this you know this case
and it generalizes to mts which is a
very general problem
which captures caching
another problem called k server and you
know various other problems what is k
server i am i'm given a metric space
i have k repairment while standing
around k fire trucks
that's right they're fire trucks k fire
trucks i have a fire at some location
that's a request i must move one of my
fire trucks to that location
which one of them should i move i want
to minimize the total cost
this is called k server this is a
general metric
if it was the uniform metric this would
be the same as page
so all these are
like various generalizations of this
idea
and so hopefully i gave you some sense
of how to solve this problem
and how to at least take the first steps
towards solving
more general problems
so you're always thinking the vector
from the same set it's just the
individual symptoms absolutely so it
doesn't generalize the things like
changing
so maybe i'll come to that in a moment
so
this this x you know this is uh
yeah i could generalize this as well so
i could make this some other fixed set
maybe even rn for instance in this case
you know maybe i just want to keep it
this way
um
but
so let me do one other thing before i
move on from uh
metrical task systems is to give you a
sense of what kind of results can be
obtained and try to relate it back a
little bit to uh
to regret minimization
so i was trying to make these
connections as much as possible
hopefully it will be interesting to you
so
this is what i want i want an algorithm
such that for every input sequence
my
hit cost
plus my movement cost is no more than
alpha times the hit cost plus movement
cost of any other solution
including the optimal solution but any
other solution
so this i want
for all y
which is
you can prove such a result with alpha
equals log n
theorem
there exists a solution uh there exists
an algorithm
that gives
alpha equals order log
actually there is an algorithm that does
even better so let me just tell you what
it gives
it gives and i'll just write it out here
1 plus epsilon
times the hit cost
plus
log n over epsilon times the movement
cost
it just says you know your solution
is at most this much
times any other solution
very nice sort of
guarantee
and the people who is uh who are uh sort
of experts in experts
their pulses is a little faster because
you know these terms sound kind of
familiar
and indeed there's a connection out here
so let me make that connection so
this this guarantee makes sense right
okay so let me make a connection so i
want to say suppose i have an algorithm
that achieves
this kind of behavior
then i can get a regret minimization
output
in the full information setting in xbox
let's do that
so let me just do the same
setting as before the costs i have a
sequence of course the costs are bounded
between zero and one
and i want to look at
my cost which is c t
times x t minus
this is what the regret minimization
will do i have to play first and then
the i see the cost
this is just you know linearity right
ctxt
plus
ct
xt minus 1 minus
what is this
let's just look at one of these guys
it's at most
the infinity norm of ct
times the l1 norm of
what do we know about the infinity norm
of uh the cost vectors when we are
playing experts we usually bound them
between zero and one
what have we done we've got c t x t plus
the movement cost
with an upper bound on my
cost and regret
this
is less than
one plus epsilon
times
c d
y t for any other solution y
plus
log n over epsilon
times
the summation of y d
from this
carry
epsilon at most half one something like
that yeah
and it depend on n
i think it should be fine
exactly and you can get like square root
type terms
as as usual we'll see in a moment
actually
okay
but in regret what do we compare to
we compare to a solution
which doesn't move right
let's say it it moves only k times
then
uh by the way using the same trick that
we did before
i'll say this is at most one plus
epsilon times
c t
y t minus 1
plus
y t minus y t minus 1.
centric as before
this trick
plus
log n
over epsilon times
summation y t minus y t minus
i mean this is smaller order term
compared to this so i'm going to just
kind of just ignore this guy
what is this
if i'm looking at a solution that
changes only k times
then this can be at most
k
this gives a regret analysis
it says
my cost
1 plus epsilon
times the cost
of any other solution
plus
k
log n over epsilon where we are moving k
times
the shifting regret analysis
let's say from zinc rich or any of the
others
and you know if yeah
so
statements like this can also give you
regrets
an analysis like this for the metrical
task system gives you a regret current
it's
is number of switches in the office in
the in this benchmark solution
exactly it's a switching regret
absolutely
good
so
there
are these connections but also the
techniques are connected
and then maybe the remaining time i have
let me give you an idea of the
techniques so that you'll see how we
prove things for
online algorithms and why the ideas are
connected but maybe you know i'll say
it's one little thing
you know
in metrical task systems i i wanted
solutions where i didn't move too often
right
minimizing my total movement cost but we
know this that for regret minimization
stability is a very important thing
we want solutions which don't move too
often
so at heart the two are very similar
the techniques are also similar for the
same reason
but you know they differ in the details
and what works in one doesn't work in
the other you're hyping stock i was
thinking oh you know which regularizers
can i use most of the time i just use
entropy as a regularizer i'm getting
ahead of myself let me shut up and tell
you a little more uh okay questions
about this while i'm erasing the pose
that was lost
that was lost
that was so i was being kind of uh vague
in the use of stability out there i
wasn't uh you know being technical in
which definition of stability was yes
so what happened to the other term i was
like x t minus one minus
oh this guy yeah ah so look at this plus
this
that's the left-hand side out here
see that most the right-hand side which
is what i wrote down next
and then i you know ignored this term
because it's you know i can really fold
this into this and then
if you're looking at zero switch regress
then you don't care about uh
so zero switch regret so you have to be
at the boundary you have to be careful
okay because uh what's happening is i'm
really talking about the number of times
why solution changes yeah and the y
solution always starts off at you know
me and opt have to always start off with
the same solution
so let's say we all start off at uniform
so then this will be the distance
between this term will be the distance
between the uniform distribution
and the
the the
fixed y that we're choosing okay so you
still end up with root something
something
you won't get anything better than the
experts guarantee which is the best you
can hope for
that was the penalty tournament
in in regret you you are making your
action before the other guy so if the
other guy says that was infinite cost
you know
there's not much to do right so you have
to restrict yourself and that comes out
very cleanly you know it pops out out
here that
it's it's the cost you pay for this look
ahead
and these are giving you subtly better
guarantees
but
in the worst case they all coincide
good okay
maybe i'll leave this for the moment and
then
other questions
because what i'll do otherwise i'll tell
you about a couple of
other problems
right
right so so this
you know if you are interested in this
thing
there's a variant of mts called unfair
mts
and this gives you this kind of
guarantee
right so
it is by criteria and
the way you
yeah the way you do this is you you play
with the
like the cost you can scale up one of
these costs so that they become of the
same order
and then uh you you uh you look at the
two aspects out here separately but they
still look very different from what we
so uh so uh
so the the the shortest way i would say
this is here is one way of getting this
kind of guarantee
the this kind of guarantee you can get
using a mirror descent based algorithm
and it's just the the trick is going to
be in the multipliers in front of the
linear term and the regular variable
by playing around with those you can
the techniques are very similar
absolutely
yeah
right
and what is the objective
so in the mts i want to minimize this
why why
the lower bound
i mean
but why do you consider the inner
product of ctn the previous time because
so what i wanted to say was
once i have this guarantee i can get a
regret guarantee as well
this is what this regret guarantee is
you know this proof is showing you this
regret so this i'll say it's regret
in this one will you get yourself and
this is
online
so in the
sort of remaining time i have let me
tell you about uh
a couple of
techniques
to uh to analyze algorithms and this
will uh give me a an excuse to tell you
about a
fairly general class of problems that we
can solve online
so here's the class of problems we can
solve online um
just you know it's a
so imagine the following lp
linear program
you all have seen linear programs right
so uh so what i want to do is i want to
i have i'm trying to minimize
summation c i x i
subject to constraints of the following
form a 1 1 x x1
at least b1
and
am1 x1
yeah and let's say all the x's are
non-negative
this is just a linear program it's a
covering linear program if you make all
these entries a's and b's c is positive
so i'm going to look at the situation
where all the a is a i j
b i
and c i
know
i'm going to not have time to write all
this so i'm just going to say minimize c
transpose x a x is at least b x is known
now consider the following situation
where the
the constraints of this
system are coming one by one
and every time a constraint comes you
have to find a solution it satisfies
this
the online aspect of it just says you
have to increase your variables
you cannot decrease
because otherwise you would say oh new
constraint came i'm going to just use
gurubi or my favorite linear programming
solver to solve
no but you can only increase if you
bought something you can't return it to
the shop
what kind of results can you get
and the claim is
that for all problems of this form
okay so basically this i'll call
monotone
lp
maybe i'll make it i'll say covering lp
solving
covering is just this property
can be done
with
see remember
this is my cost
i want to relate this cost to the
optimal cost
let's say the comparative ratio
is that most order
log of the number of questions
so i can give you a bunch of
constraints one by one
and you can only increase variables
and still at the end you'll say hey here
is a solution whose cost is no more than
log m times the optimal cost
let me give you an example
let's do it
suppose i said x1 plus x2 this is my
first oh so i want to minimize summation
i tell you the constraint you say okay
all the variables are
equally important
i say x1 plus x2 plus xm
and n is equal to m let's say
as many constraints as variables
this one plus xm
is at least one
what should we do
we don't know anything about the future
so you better increase all your
variables equally
because here's what's going to happen
next
i'm going to drop one of these variables
let's say it's 1 but
then i'll say x2 plus x3
plus xn
then x3 plus
i'm going to give you constraints like
this and x and
of course here in this example i've
dropped the first variable the second
variable third variable and so on so
forth but really think of this as
dropping a random variable from this to
get the next constraint a random
variable from this to get the next
constraint and so on so foreign
but it's a i'm allowing you fractional
solutions as well
so it's like the fractional solution of
the category what you could think of is
the probability distribution of where
the mouse should be
that's two steps ahead of me
uh
but just think about this right now
you know what should you do you know you
know nothing about the future
you should probably spread your mass
equally you should spread all the way
all the mass one over m on everybody
and then
this mass this one over m mass that you
put
on this guy
is never going to be used it's a loss
mass
next time you lose you'll increase all
the variables equally pretty much
everything's been selected
we'll put 1 over m minus 1
on all the variables but this this
variable will never be used again
how much are you losing 1 over m 1 over
m minus 1 1 over n minus 2 and so on so
forth this is harmonic number of m log m
what's the optimal solution
this one
you have a solution of cos log n after
the solution of one
log in
this shows that you know essentially
there is a log m gap in this instance
there's nothing else
you can make that formal if you
absolutely insist
so there is one and uh so you can you
can talk about exactly the dual problem
which is the maximization the packing
version
and that we can solve but there we have
to violate the capacities a little bit
so
in general that becomes difficult to
solve because you know it's good
sort of talk we'll talk about packing
problems and you know packing problems
are difficult
because if you come to the limit
and i give you a very lucrative
item how are you going to add that
so
usually we violate the capacity
but for now let's do
covering
yeah so this is a fractional solution
where it does not depend on the number
of variables oh wow so even
and in fact there are algorithms where
the number of variables are actually
exponentially many but the number of
constraints are small so you can
actually
do good things
of course
running time-wise that's the problem
but then
let's not go there for the moment
this made sense right that look the
constraints came up one by one i
maintained a solution that was always
rising
and still my final solution wasn't that
bad it was only log and bad compared to
the optimal situation
this you can do for any covering entry
of this right this is covering lpa all
covering lps with this form you can do
it
let me show you what the algorithm is
and for
uh
the special case
where all
well all the numbers are one
abc's oh maybe not all of them are one
they're either there or one
i'll give you an
algorithm
for the special case so special case
fractional
sector the
thing looks like minimize
summation
in fact
imagine all the
uh
all the columns are sets
so what is that cover side cover there's
a uni universe
and there's a bunch of sets
this is s2 this is s3 and there are
elements which belong to some of these
i want to pick
sets to cover the elements
so i want to say minimize the number of
sets i pick fractional
such that
look at the first element out here
one so i'll give you an element
and i'll say all the sets
such that e1 belongs to that set
amongst all those sets big one
and then i'll give you an element e2
this is really an lp of this one
this is exactly the kind of lp i was
using okay
i just give you a bunch of you know
say x1 plus x3 plus x7
with at least one and then i'll say x2
plus x9
with at least one and you know
constraints like this
the only specialization i've made is all
that all the entries are 01.
the problem here
how should i explain this
so here's an idea
the idea is multiplicative ways
so here's what we
let me tell you the algorithm
the algorithm is going to be
look at any variable
xs
if it belongs suppose this constraint
just came in
i want to raise some of these variables
right
this constraint just came in these two
variables had some values i want to
raise them
suppose x2 has a lot of value already
it should kind of tell me that
like x2 was important somehow in the
past
i should rate it more aggressively
so i am going to raise x2
so
when
element
e arrives
w
if
summation
of s
such that e belongs to s x s
is at least one
we are happy
we wanted to satisfy this constraint lo
and behold it's satisfied
suppose not
take all the elements that contain the
sets that contain element e and double
the rates get richer
which had a large value have even larger
what happens if this either overshoots
one or doesn't quite reach good so if
this you know
the arrow is supposed to mean you know
you you go back through this loop again
so
um if it doesn't you know initially all
the values were let's say very small you
double them it's still like you know
very small
go back again double them again
double them again until you know they
were just below one they overshoot they
go to at least two at most two
not a big deal
we're losing logs out here when we get
more sophisticated
there is a problem
if there is some excess
which can potentially cover
so the question is what do i start off
with
that's exactly it right
so let's do the following thing there
are many ways of handling this but let
me just use the one which is the easiest
xs
is
um
1 over
2 m let's say 1 over m
for all sets
so i'm paying a fractional cost of one
there are m sets by the way
m is the number of sets so
yes
i think your notation you should have
log m in your monotone covering output
like n is your number of variables
but now you have m as the number of
variables oh okay
no i think your competitive red should
be log n right and not log m in the blue
text
like when you do the randomized line you
would log
the number of constraints but this is
the number of times okay so ruler is
absolutely right that's the reason why i
was making the mistake
i think so yeah i think so
sorry about changing something on a
previous board that's that's not a
kosher move but uh
there's nothing i can do right now
then i'll have to take it back
whatever you were saying the exponential
number of constraints is okay
exponential number of variables not okay
thank you
so let me go back to this
no you should probably use um
it's confusing
okay good
number of sets is that
okay
but let's go back to you know
don't worry about the parameters
hopefully i'm not confusing you too much
when an element arrives
oh initially i i gave like one over n to
every set
in total i've played one
right one is you know maybe it's an
additive loss of one we can get rid of
this this is not important
and then whenever an element of time
and i double again and i double again
until the constraint is satisfied
and then i go
so
that's my my algorithm and how do i
analyze oh so my claim is my theorem
that i want to say
is that this algorithm
is
order
log n
i need to
analyze
these break signs between the s's when
you double wow so i double all the s's
that contain this element
so intuitively there's one s that is
very large it contains everything
uh yes so you know it could be the case
that there's one s which is already at
one minus epsilon and all the other
assets are sitting at this
so in that case that s will become two
almost two
that's fine this constraint is satisfied
you could have just proportionately
increased everything exactly so so you
know i'm just trying to make things
simple maybe you should just
proportionately increase and really you
should do multiplicative ways
some continuous version of this
but let's just analyze this
how do i analyze this guy i know
you know three ways of doing this uh
since i'm going so slow i can only do
one and hint at another
but let me do one
so here's here
so this is the time to recall lp duality
just a little bit
the linear program that we are writing
is minimize
uh summation of xs such that
combination of excess s containing e
is at least one
for all elements e which which we have
seen you know in seen so far
and
xs is non-negative
and you remember it's dual
it's maximized summation
y e
uh constrain a variable for every
element
such that
y e
is at most one
and y either non-negative
the recovery problem there's a backing
problem
[Music]
okay
so the analysis is going to be in three
steps
the first step
is
every time i do this oh okay so here's
what i'm going to do
every time i do one round of
this thing
along with doubling the xs i'm going to
set y e
i'm going to increment y
here
constraint correspond to elements
so when this constraint came a new
variable appeared in the dual
its value was zero
element arrives y e is set to zero
and now every time i doubled the primal
variables
i increase the dual variable by one
you think back to what were primals and
duals you know
the dual is the way of charging the
primer it gives a lower bound on the
frame
i'm just constructing a lot
the first thing i'm going to
observe
is that when an element arrived
how much did the you know let's look at
one loop one round of this loop
how much did the primal change
some variables were doubled right
the sum of those variables was less than
one
the increment is less than one
they were 0.99 they're 1.98 the
difference is 0.9
the difference is exactly the sum
every time i i did this portion
the prime will change by at most one
the dual change
y
at every point
the primal is at most the dual change
this happens at every time step
so the final prime p final
which is my cost
is at most the final
now
if the final duels were feasible
what do we know about the final dual the
dual is the lower bound on the optimal
solution right
this should be by weak duality this is
at most
the optimal prime
i would have the final my final
primarily that most the optimal track
i have a better than optimal solution
this is amazing
so the point is going to be so here this
is only true if the dual bless you if
the dual is feasible
so the dual is not going to be useful
what i'll show
and this is going to be the final step
and for this maybe i'll use this part of
the board
well actually i could have just written
there but the final step step three
is that the
y e divided by let's say log n
maybe constant times log n
are feasible
i'm losing a login factor
log
n thank you
and sometimes keep colliding
i just need to show this
so let's just do that
what's the dual constraint
the dual constraint says
all the elements in a set must pack to
at least one
so in order to show this
i need to show that all these things
some to at least atmosphere again
look at this status oh
for all this
look at the settings
and look at the elements that belong to
it
when did i raise their value
every time i raised their value by one
i doubled all these
variables that included f
every time i increased one of the y's by
one
i raised excess by a factor of two
where did xs start off
one over there
what is the final value of xs
at most one
because you know if if a set is set to
more than one it will never be raised it
by itself will cover all itself
xs started off at one over n every time
it was doubled the y e got increased
and excess can never be more than one
because otherwise this if condition
would be satisfied just by itself
okay anyways that's the
but here here we have the summation of y
e in the set of x
uh we could have
so we could optimize this thing further
uh i don't know if
the size of
s so the reason why i don't you know i'm
not saying size of s i'm just saying
look at any element in s that was
uh that caused excess to double
that's the element that it's you know
every time y e for some e goes up by one
excess doubles
you you would get like log
the maximum number of sets and elements
part of by doing what you you could
instead of initializing
so what i could do
is i could set this to be
instead of number of
like instead of double x like if someone
is arriving you can put the sets of
those guys to be one over the number of
sets covering that element
uh sure
instead of doing this doubling one by
one i could
so instead of initialized by one well
anyway i say that you could like refine
what you're saying i think is to get
like log of the frequency like uh okay
which is like the maximum number of sets
they can cover on or like the support of
the construct so what uh ullah is saying
is that this log n and what you're
saying is that this log n
instead of being the number of sets
it could be log
of the maximum
number of
sets
that
but you know i'm not optimizing the
important thing was
there three you know there were two
ideas in this proof the first
there was one idea in the algorithm
which is that multiplicative ways
you know if a set was important in the
past chances are it's going to be
important in the future
fast performance is no predictor of
future returns but that's the best hope
we have
if we don't know anything about the
future
that's the idea out here so you double
and the second the idea and the proof is
that you use the dual as a charging
mechanism
to show that the cost is not too high
so
maybe at this point i'll mention
two other things
what you can do is you can do a
continuous version of this
so that instead of increasing the
instead of doubling s
you could maybe go back to here
and i'll increase
i'll say that x s prime you know this is
the derivative so i'm going to increase
the excess
at rate
x s
plus you know 1 over n that's the same
one over n out there
over the cost of s
then i can handle costs as well
actually i can yeah
so you can have a continuous increase
like this
um once you see this kind of continuous
increase you might say well what's
really happening is there are
is there a
sort of a deeper connection
with the kind of regret based algorithms
and the techniques there or the
continuous algorithms
and so in fact what you can do
is here is what here's here the
different solution that you can do
so you can say whenever a new element
arrives
solve this problem it's actually a kind
of a
different way of viewing it that the new
solution
at time t
is
the old solution or whatever so is is
like a kl divergence between
the solution and the previous solution
that
x is
a
b transpose x
so look at solutions
which satisfy the new constraint
and we minimize the distance in the kl
divergence
this problem
will give you a multiplicative weights
update
this is perhaps a more general way of
viewing these uh algorithms that you
know our our solution space these are
covering problems
our solution space is continuously
moving upwards
so if i'm sitting out here and a new
constraint comes in i want to move to a
feasible point
which feasible point should i move to
what these algorithms are doing is that
they are projecting this point onto the
feasible region but the projection is
not in l2
it's
using the kl divergence
so maybe you know i won't get more into
this but if you're interested i can
point you to uh
references and
we can talk some more
so so kind of a vast area so i was
trying to cover as many
uh techniques as possible
hopefully you got a sense of that maybe
i will mention i'll take two more
minutes of your time
so where do you go next right i mean
this whole area
uh
so there the way i view it is there are
several
uh directions which are very promising
one is there are many classical problems
which are still open
i mentioned the k server problem the the
fire trucks moving around
we don't understand that problem for
instance
completely there are some gaps between
upper and lower pawns and many such
landmark problems are still there
but
one direction that i'm particularly
excited about and which uh
shushi and ellen will talk about
is how can we go beyond the worst case
i would like to have algorithms that are
so bad or so good you know
that have a guarantee in every case the
robustness guarantee that we have out
here but on good instances are better
if we have more information we should do
better
so the question is you know can we get
algorithms which are more nuanced
well i have maybe stochastic predictions
about the future
where i'm given 20 instances and 21st is
promised to be similar
so there's this huge kind of spectrum
between the knob of you know uh
the pessimistic uh
the kind of robust bounce that we get
and the offline bounds that we can vote
for
and uh so you know that is something
that perhaps this group of people is
particularly
suited to
because
these are the kind of things that
interest you as
far as i see so hopefully we can talk
more about that if you have questions
i'm happy to answer them
yeah you said you had three proofs you
asked one yes manchester under the two
others so so one other proof is you can
write down uh
a potential function
and you can show that
this kind of update rule let's
for that kind of you know all these
update rules are essentially the same
it decreases the potential
so
you start off the potential as the
optimal solution and then you decrease
your distance to the potential
so that's a potential function based
proof and the third proof is via
this kind of uh projection
so arguing that these kind of bregman
projections actually give you a good
solution
but this is the easiest thing
we started with the simpler problem like
this key rental where we're able to
enumerate you know strata actions and we
explicitly wrote the prime like the
basically the minimax combination and so
for it can i think of this primal dual
argument is
some form of relaxation because i cannot
explicitly write down policies and
instances so this is some form of a
projection of that
you know a minimax combination or is it
so is it fair to think about it this way
it's very fair it's often the way i do
think about it
but i don't offer like a a formal
argument
but you know that is pretty much the way
i think about it that i can't write down
the entire game matrix and stuff so this
is one way of projecting it down into a
smaller space
so for these kind of covering problems
monotonicity comes for free so if you
just look at the kkt conditions for this
the monitor monotonicity just pops out
for other problems where you actually
you know
it's not a covering problem things get
hairy and that's where the fun begins
uh
no but there should be
and uh
it it really comes down to the
unconstrained versus constrained
optimization in the issue so there's
some technical details but there should
be
[Music]
i can still have monotonicity so
what happens is in
sort of integral set cover is that i can
take the fractional solution and i can
do randomized rounding on that
i lose the log factor above this thing
for the randomized rounding
but uh i can maintain monotonicity
so you know
variables the fractional is just in my
head and then i'm doing randomized
rounding on that now
each time i'm rounding i can get a
different solution but there are ways to
de-randomize it as well and then you can
be actually
uh with probability one
be you know getting the same solution be
monotone and all that but integral
solutions
you're only adding
so this this monastery constraints like
uh what's the better way to think about
it is that is it something that that is
our visitor atom per se or is it just
like
it's cool to say oh we're making
consistent progress
so so it is
you know at least in this setting it's a
it's a desired property
that you know if i bought a set i cannot
return it
because otherwise if you were just given
a new constraint one thing you could do
is you could just solve the l2 again
like this sure so so you know you can
change the problem this is just part of
the problem specification
removing it and adding other constraints
will be perfectly reasonable
so i mean
maybe there is a the naive
representation of uh
of side
mts has this problem that the
the distances are not symmetric
you know i can go from this state to the
other state
but you know i can add a set but i can't
remove a set but if i remove a set i
don't get the money back
so at least naively i don't see how to
make it work but there might be a
different representation which allows us
with a convex body that changes
right so in the
mts
you didn't allow us to change the
decision effect which was always a
simple example absolutely
to change then it can capture this
problem
because every time that you get to see a
new element you have a linear constraint
that you use
so the intersection can you have space
that you have to configure that changes
the set that you are going to make
so
what you're talking about is a situation
like mts where instead of
me always outputting a point in in the
probability simplex i output it in some
polytope
maybe that's a definite maybe i don't
know
other questions
people ready for lunch
can you be careful here to get the
that's another maybe i don't know i uh
i haven't uh
tried
in that case i think we can take time to
spend time time again
we will have to talk
you